realice transformaciones en el
cuadrilátero móvil hasta que coincidan
con el cuadrilátero teo a de la figura
resultante es congruente a la original
bueno aquí está en nuestro cuadrilátero
móvil y aquí está la figura a la que nos
están preguntando si es congruente o no
la figura t o ade y aquí abajo tenemos
nuestras herramientas traslación
rotación reflexión o potencia y deshacer
pero antes de usarlas quiero que
analicemos que necesitamos hacer para
responder a esta pregunta
vamos a usar nuestro pizarrón aquí está
la figura que tenemos que hacer para que
esto coincida con esta figura bueno
observando la me da la impresión de que
este segmento de aquí es este de acá y
nos convendría mover este punto para que
coincida con el punto que tenemos que
hacer para mover este punto de acá acá
tendríamos primero que desplazarnos de
aquí sobre el eje x
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis lugares a
la derecha y sobre el eje y bajar uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis lugares para
llegar a este punto así que lo que
haríamos aquí es una traslación vamos a
ponerla acá trasladar
seis lugares a la derecha sería seis
sobre el eje x y menos seis lugares o
seis lugares hacia abajo en el eje y
entonces ya movimos este punto este otro
punto sería seis lugares hacia la
derecha uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
seis lugares hacia abajo 1 2 3 4 5 6
estaría aquí este punto 6 a la derecha 1
2 3 4 5 6 y 6 hacia abajo 1 2 3 4 5 6
quedaría aquí y este otro punto 6 a la
derecha 6 hacia abajo quedaría aquí voy
a ponerlo en otro color de manera que la
figura trasladada con este vector
quedaría así así
y así ok entonces pues ya la tenemos
trasladada aquí y bueno vemos que más o
menos si está coincidiendo que podemos
hacer pues podemos reflejar o podemos
aplicar o motes ya yo creo que vamos
primero a aplicarla o motes ya como
decía es cambiar las dimensiones hacerlo
más chiquito o más grande y tenemos que
encontrar un punto central donde se va a
aplicar esto que yo creo va a ser este
punto de acá lo voy a poner en otro
color este punto de acá él lo que es las
coordenadas tres menos tres entonces va
a ser potencia
en el punto 3 menos 3 y cuánto vamos a
modificar las dimensiones queremos que
todo este segmento coincida con este o
de acá
teo mide 2 cuadritos y este otro
segmento mide 1 2 3 4 5 6 6 entre 2 nos
da 3 vamos a reducirlo tres veces así
que va a ser un tercio en una proporción
de un tercio bueno entonces si lo
reducimos una tercera parte este
segmento va a quedar aquí ahora este
segmento de acá son tres cuadritos pues
bueno una tercera parte de esto va a ser
un cuadrito así que va a quedar acá este
punto de acá de nuestro punto de origen
a este punto son tres lugares hacia la
izquierda y seis lugares hacia arriba
así que en lugar de tener tres lugares a
la derecha va a ser un lugar va a estar
en esta parte y en lugar de seis va a
tener
de altura va a estar a tan reducimos la
distancia hacia arriba y la distancia en
el eje x de manera que éstos se redujera
una tercera parte y ahora nuestra figura
cuando le aplicamos la o motes ya al
reducirla nos queda algo así este que
esté acá y esté acá
lo único que nos queda y parece que si
está coincidiendo al menos las
distancias es reflejarlo y tendríamos
que elegir un eje de reflexión este eje
de reflexión coincidiría con esta línea
horizontal que pasa sobre sí igual a
menos 3 la ecuación de esta línea es
igual a menos 3 y aquí aplicamos la
reflexión de manera que si dibujamos una
línea perpendicular de cada punto de la
figura hacia este eje de reflexión y
hacemos lo mismo del otro lado
respetando las mismas distancias vamos a
tener esta figura reflejada de este
punto acá recorremos dos cuadritos y si
lo recorremos hacia abajo coincide con
el punto de este punto coincide con el
punto o igual el t está en el mismo
lugar y este punto de acá es un cuadrito
hacia la línea y si de esta línea
hacemos un cuadrito hacia abajo coincide
con el punto a de manera que si la
reflejamos va a coincidir con esta
figura original que es el cuadrilátero
teo
así que reflejamos sobre la línea
igual a menos 3 y bueno podemos dar dos
puntos sobre esta línea esta línea sus
coordenadas son aquí hay unas 0 - 3 y
bueno como estamos viendo pues no
importa qué valor tengamos en x layer
siempre va a valer menos 3 así que por
ejemplo el punto 7 coma menos 3 también
corresponde con esta línea
ahora vamos a usar todo este análisis
con las herramientas de nuestro portal
regresamos a la página y en bueno lo
primero que hicimos fue hacer una
traslación lo movimos 6 hacia la derecha
y menos 6 que son 6 hacia abajo ahí está
hicimos potencia el centro de nuestra
potencia fue el punto 3 menos 3
coma menos 3 pues no quiero que se mueva
la figura que ya la tengo aquí ubicada y
la escala fue de una tercera parte un
tercio y aquí está finalmente lo que
hicimos fue una reflexión sobre la línea
de igual a menos tres y bueno como esta
línea no importa qué valor se tenga en x
siempre vale y menos 3 pues aquí podemos
poner cualquier número en esta
coordenada 0 - 3 mientras ponga menos 3
en la parte de y no importa 7 - 3 y aquí
ya aplicamos la reflexión y vemos que
coinciden exactamente bueno ya vimos que
coinciden pero nos preguntan si son
congruentes como tuvimos que aplicar o
motes ya cambiarles las dimensiones ya
con eso con ese simple hecho nos indica
que no van a ser congruentes no tienen
las mismas dimensiones así que no las
figuras no son congruentes